hi my name is bonnie goldstein
and i'm going to be speaking about
medical cannabis for children
i'm the medical director of canna
center's wellness and education which is
a medical practice in los angeles
that helps patients use cannabis as
medicine
might just quickly my background i've
been a california
licensed physician for 30 years i
trained at children's hospital la
and was chief resident there i went into
the
field of critical care transport
medicine at children's and then went
into the field of pediatric emergency
medicine
where i worked for about 13 years in
2008 my eyes were open to
cannabis by a sick friend and i made a
transition
from pediatric er into the world of
medical cannabis and
since 2008 i've treated over 18 000
patients including
over a thousand children at this point i
have multiple affiliations
uh including a board member of the
international association for
cannabinoid medicines
and just recently joined americans for
safe access and nonprofit on their
policy advisory committee i
recently published my second book which
is called cannabis is medicine
which was written for both layperson as
well as healthcare providers
to kind of give and all around to
exactly what i'm doing
in my practice how cannabis works is
medicine what conditions it might help
as well as multiple patient testimonials
now i'd like to start off with the story
of a little boy i started seeing
a number of years ago his name is isaiah
and his mom
love to send me these cardboard uh
updates and so here you can see he says
my name is isaiah i'm eight years old i
have intractable epilepsy
no pharmaceutical has ever stopped my
seizures ever i was having seizures
every
30 to 45 seconds today i'm one month
pharmaceutical free and six months
seizure free
excuse me this is a young man whose
mother when she brought him
in shared with me that she has a brother
now an adult who is fully debilitated by
an uncontrolled seizure disorder that
just never responded to medication and
he requires full-time care
and she also had a sister so who had
seizures as well so there may be
something certainly genetic in this
family unfortunately their insurance
would not approve for them to get tested
but she said to me that she
could not let her son uh grow up
and be debilitated like her brother she
unfortunately had already lived through
that
and so uh here's the beginning of his
journey
i got another little sign a year later
a one year seizure free five months
pharmaceutical free
and then another one two years seizure
free one year pharma free
and as you can see he's looking great in
these
photos and then uh in october 2019
in fact i was abroad actually giving a
talk that day about
medical cannabis i woke up to this
text celebrating five years seizure free
and as you can see in this top picture
is him when he very first came to me he
was a little guy
and at the bottom there he is with his
new baby brother
and then just last year here he is
november 2020 they live on a farm and
these are his uh
piglets and uh this young man is doing
uh terrifically on cannabis medicine
i really believe he's gotten his life
back and just to share with you his
dosing for
he's getting about eight milligrams per
kilo per day again we use weight
for epilepsy he also has a history of
autism
and cbd helped a little bit but we had
to add in thc to help with some
aggressive behaviors and some of the
focus and also some self-injurious type
stuff
and he's also getting thc and as you can
see if you calculate out he's getting
about a six to one ratio
of cbd to thc and we will talk about
this a little uh
more in the presentation but i love to
show
isaiah's story because it really shows
how
life-changing cannabis can be as
medicine
when medically supervised for children
with
intractable epilepsy and or autism
in my practice i see patients with many
conditions
of course the main two are treatment
resistant epilepsy intractable epilepsy
and autism
we also see patients with cancer mostly
advanced cancers or
cancers with poor prognosis adhd
some psychiatric conditions tourette
syndrome
i do have a number of patients that have
chronic pain
due to various uh rare conditions
autoimmune disorders genetic conditions
and
and also unfortunately end of life just
to share with you this is thomas
he's a young man in my practice that has
a genetic condition
had severe self-injurious behavior
intractable seizures chronic vomiting
um unable to walk in fact in his first
visit in my office came in a wheelchair
and he was
not able to walk as you can see and
this is a follow-up appointment after
starting cannabis
seizures are down over 90 percent uh he
has
self-injurious behavior is down over 90
percent the vomiting
completely stopped uh within a few
months of initiating cannabis
treatment and he began walking and uh
thomas as his mother says every year
just uh
brings him to a better place he's doing
wonderfully
now what's our rationale for use so
there is evidence of endocannabinoid
system dysfunction in both
epilepsy and autism as well as a number
of other
conditions certainly this is understudy
but that we do have some clear-cut
evidence which i'll share with you
uh cannabis despite the reefer madness
propaganda that persists under medical
supervision cannabis has an
excellent safety profile and is
tolerated well by most people
i don't see organ damage i certainly see
improved quality of life
certainly compassionate care end of life
patients should have access to something
that helps
soothe them and help with passing
and very importantly over just the last
decade we've had this increased
availability of tested products
and different cannabinoid terpenoid
profiles including cbd cbg
thca c cbda thc cbc
all these different cannabinoids mixed
with various terpenes
there's a full array of products so that
we can customize
treatment to benefit each patient and
i make this statement at every talk i
give with medical supervision there is
clear
clinical evidence of significant
benefits with no toxicity
my patients all if they have side
effects and i guess i'll
i'll talk about this again at the end um
we just don't tolerate side effects we
change it up we change the cannabinoid
we change the product we change the
timing we change the dosing
there is no reason for these children to
have any side effects
and i can say with
seriousness that my patients do not
suffer
side effects when they're on the proper
cannabis
regiment now
let me just go back uh i just want to
share with you this
young man and his sister are both of my
patients they both struggle with
autism and epilepsy as well as a number
of other conditions
and gavin is in my book is the first
story in my book
he brings a smile to my face because
he's a sweetheart he is
when he came in at the age of four he's
now 10.
he was really struggling the family uh
you know the mom
and both grandmas came in they were all
in tears uh this child
was really having a very difficult life
and uh he has just been a tremendous
success story
his sister became my patient a few years
later and
both of them are just thriving with
the use of cannabis
and multiple cannabinoids both of them
are using cbd
thc thca and also
cbda for uh gavin
uh now just very briefly the
endocannabinoid system we know about
this system as it was discovered in the
late 80s and early 90s so we've only had
a
few decades to learn about it and study
uh luckily there's a lot of interest
globally and many researchers are are
studying it
what is this what are we talking about
when we talk about the endocannabinoid
system and basically it's a physiologic
regulator of cellular messages with the
goal
of homeostasis of balancing cellular
messages so remember
when you have an insult inflammation
some type of
external or internal environment change
you your body says oh here's this hit
now i want to get back into balance
that's that's it's an adaptive
regulator uh to try to help you send
a balanced messages and it consists of
receptors
uh compounds that we call
endocannabinoids which
if you get confused just call them inner
cannabis endo means from within and two
that have been studied the most are
anandamide 2ag there are others
and also part of the system are enzymes
that make your endocannabinoids
and enzymes that degrade the
endocannabinoids and again the job of
this system is to protect
repair and recover and i have a
schematic here that shows
basically a blue cell on top that's the
presynaptic neuron
and the cell on the bottom that's
represented in pink
is your postsynaptic neuron and the
little purple circles on the right hand
side
are neurotransmitters and those are
being sent from one cell to another the
top
to the bottom from the sending cell to
the receiving cell
and when that message is off because of
some
internal external environment influence
when those messages are often usually
it's an over message what we call over
excitation there's too much
neurotransmitter the receiving cell the
pink cell at the bottom
gets annoyed and allows calcium to flood
into it
which then turns on the little factory
which is kind of the green little
shape there which releases your
endocannabinoid backwards what we call
retrograde backwards to the sending cell
where and those are the little green
triangles or your anandamide
or your 2ag and they go back up to the
cell they stick onto the cannabinoid
receptor which is the
blue or navy squiggly line they attach
like a key in a lock
which then sells sends a message to the
rescending cell
hey turn down the message stop sending
so much neurotransmitter
it is a feedback loop it is telling your
cells stop
sending an imbalanced message and really
the goal of this is to protect repair
and recover to keep you
in balance and when we look at the role
of the endocannabinoid system in the
brain
as well as in the body the
endocannabinoid system is involved
in almost every physiologic function
including contr
cognition motor control emotional
response motivated behavior
neural development appetite food intake
even more in the brain
and in the in the body uh tremendous
influence over the
immune function gastrointestinal system
reproduction
uh reproductive system and energy
metabolism as well as others
and again the goal is homeostasis
balance so when we take cannabis
medicine
we are targeting the endocannabinoid
system now
unfortunately i don't have enough time
to go through but also we know that
these
compounds in the cannabis plant also
target
cells or receptors and
have other targets outside of the
endocannabinoid system and there's a
huge amount of research going on there
so these are compounds
that can not only help balance
using the endocannabinoid system but
also target
other mechanisms to give their benefits
and this is why research is so important
and we must be free to
to do research so that we can really
understand exactly um
where these compounds are working and
what influence they have over our
physiologic function
now intractable epilepsy so i'm going to
talk about epilepsy and then we'll talk
about autism
epilepsy affects about one percent of
the world population
about 30 to 35 percent of patients don't
respond to medications
uh childhood epilepsy has twice uh the
incidence of
adult uh epilepsy about 700 cases per
100
000 children so it's actually um uh
quite prevalent um and what what do we
call intractable epilepsy other terms
are
refractory or treatment resistant
uh the definition is failure to respond
to an adequate trial of two medications
either alone or in combination
we know that after two drugs fail
there is about a one to four percent
chance that another
uh anti-epileptic uh drug will
benefit so after those first two drugs
have been tried the chances of
responding
fall tremendously and of course the
burden in children
includes irreversible brain damage from
uncontrolled seizures behavioral motor
issues and of course
increased morbidity and mortality and
just to share this is a photo of olivia
she's also in my book
she's a little girl that had a stroke
while still
in utero and she was born with seizures
and multiple other issues and she has
been seizure free on cbd oil now
i think going on six years tremendous
results
and just a big quality of life
difference for her
now um the endocannabinoid system has
been shown to be somewhat dysfunctional
in patients with epilepsy
there is many studies that look at this
and um i can't go
possibly through all of them but i've
highlighted a few here
in looking at epileptic brain tissue
that was removed surgically
when someone was having an operation
when compared to healthy post-mortem
brain there were numerous abnormalities
found in the endocannabinoid system
we also know that if you block that
receptor and don't allow
endocannabinoids to bind to it
this can produce what we call status
epilepticus which is an uncontrolled
prolonged
dangerous uh seizure uh and we also know
that
newly uh diagnosed uh patients with uh
and people who have not started
medication yet that have temporal lobe
epilepsy when
a cerebral spinal fluid was removed with
a
lumbar puncture spinal tap the levels of
anandamide
which is their endocannabinoid were
reduced and
from a very a very helpful article uh
published by davinski at allen 2014 that
discusses how cannabinoids may
influence seizures you know the
statement which
you know kind of sums it up
endocannabinoids play an intrinsic
protective role in calming
over-excitation of neurons exactly what
seizures
are which is over-excitation too much
firing
now when we look at cbd and cmg's gotten
a lot of attention
you know how does it work why does it
stop seizures and what we know about cbd
is that
it has uh properties of what we call
polypharmacy it works at
multiple sites uh in the brain not just
one target multiple targets and
all these targets result in inhibition
of neuronal excitation and without
getting into too much detail
cbd targets a number of non-cannabinoid
receptors including gpr 55 and trpv1
cbd also increases extracellular
adenosine inhibiting
uptake which decreases seizures there's
also some possible
interaction with gaba receptors we know
also that cbd
inhibits the breakdown of your
anandamide which is your own natural
endocannabinoid
so basically allowing anandamide to have
a
more of an action uh enhancing your
anandamide enhances your own natural
endocannabinoid function
as well as two very important properties
for a brain that is having seizures
anti-inflammatory and
neuroprotective in multiple
um uh aspects
uh including decreasing glutamate which
is a neurotransmitter that when
released in excess during seizures can
be
damaging to the brain now we do know
that there are
other uh cannabinoids from the cannabis
plant that have anti-convulsant effects
i do often use thca which is the raw
form of thc tetrahydrocannabinolic acid
we
know from research it's an
anti-inflammatory neuroprotectant and
also an immune immunomodulator
it is reported not to cross the
blood-brain barrier however
this is still somewhat up in the air as
there are some evidence that
patients with seizures people with
autoimmune disorders
may have a compromised blood brain
barrier so
that is still a big question mark at
this point but
there's no question in my mind that thca
works because i have patients who do
did not respond to cbd who take thca
and are seizure free uh we have one
animal model showing uh that high doses
are anti-convulsant
and then you know the rest of our
reports are anecdotal
and some patients respond at low doses
and some at higher doses
i have um the patients using this we
find kind of what we call the sweet spot
dose where there's little to no side
effects
looking basically for the lowest dose
that gives the desired effect and like i
said i have
numerous patients that thca either by
itself or added in with other
cannabinoids has been
anti-convulsant and again at this point
the mechanism of action is unknown
when we look at thc we do see that the
data in animals
is conflicting but mostly
anti-convulsant in low doses when you
give
sky-high doses to animals that can cause
seizures
but the overall evidence is more towards
anticonvulsant effects
we don't have clinical trials in humans
but we have many anecdotal reports
from patients that report seizure
reduction there is a mechanism of action
reported decreasing glutamate which i've
discussed
and i have found clinically that thc is
helpful
in low non-impairing doses especially
when combined with cbd or thca
the only downside really with thc is
certainly that tolerance may occur but
there are some strategies that you can
employ
to minimize tolerance and that includes
making sure that there are other
cannabinoids in the mix including cbd
two other cannabinoids that uh do have
some anti-convulsant effects cbdv
uh this has been looked at and it has
been found to be anti-convulsant in
multiple
animal models and appears to be additive
with cbd
cbdv also inhibits the uptake of
anandamide again
enhancing a person's own natural
endocannabinoid function
there was a study from gw pharmaceutical
looking at cbdv in adults
with high doses but it failed to reach
the primary endpoints and i just say
this is was used as a single compound as
far as i understand not as a whole plant
and then there's an interesting um
report in the literature of a young
adult with
rasmussen encephalitis which is kind of
a devastating neurodegenerative disorder
that includes severe seizures
where uh this young man had dozens of
seizures a day and he took
a homemade cannabis preparation that his
parents made for him
from cannabis flour and he had
significant reduction of seizures and
improvement in his neurocognitive
function and when they
gave him this homemade preparation and
drew blood levels they found this
correlation between high serum cb
dv levels and clinical improvement and
when those levels dropped
his clinical improvement uh decreased as
well and then when those levels of cbdv
in his bloodstream went back
up he showed improvement again so i do
believe there's something there and of
course
again the freedom to study cbdv in human
clinical trials
would be very helpful and i believe in a
whole plant
preparation and then more recently cbda
i started using this in patients a
number of years ago when it became
available in california market
there was a study published just a
couple months ago here in 2021
that shows that it has anti-convulsion
effects
similar and they use the word comparable
to cbd
i have seen this in patients gw
took a patent out in 2017 showing uh
that cbda was effective
for seizure reduction under certain
conditions with better bioavailability
and faster onset
that wasn't published in scientific
literature but you can't find that in
their patent
i am using cbda more and more um
as it um appears in
from my uh clinical experience that
sometimes less expensive lower doses can
really give some enhancement
uh to these patients struggling with
epilepsy
now i'm just comparing uh four
retrospective surveys
remember again we are prohibited with
clinical trials with research but
we have four surveys that i can show you
just in the last
five or six years um doc
the first one you can see hussein 2015
this is out of
ucla where they surveyed 117 families
who were giving cbd
to their uh children with intractable
epilepsy many of those patients
overlapping with my practice as they see
me for their cannabis and go to ucla for
their pediatric neurology appointments
as you can see under the percent of
parents reporting seizure reduction 85
percent
reported seizure reduction 14 seizure
freedom
um and if you move to the next
in 2016 this is from israel where they
gave patients a 20 to 1 ratio
of cbd a total patient count of 74
patients with intractable epilepsy
very similar number 89 reported seizure
reduction
and then if you look at across the top
sulak al
2017 i co-authored this with dustin
sulak out of maine
and dr russell sonato out of seattle
children's hospital we had a total
combined 272 patients and saw 86 percent
um reduction of um
seizures and um and you can see
uh the last one measured things a little
bit different in 2018 but they saw 39
of patients reported a greater than 50
percent reduction
and um if you look you know uh
take a look at benefits we see better
sleep better alertness mood
all across very similar reports of
of side benefits not side effects
but if you look at the bottom for side
effects certainly tolerable appetite
increase drowsiness some fatigue or
sedation
and in the article that i co-authored
with my two colleagues
uh we did look at liver function uh
tests and we did not see any change even
in patients with a
high dose and as you can see here i just
highlight the numbers
uh that you give us uh the percent
reporting
uh seizure reduction and also seizure
freedom and remember
the seizure freedom numbers are not
spectacular
right 10 14 but remember this is
patients who are
um having intractable epilepsy and who
have very
uh few other options left on the table
when we look at uh what we now have on
the market at the dialects it's the
first plant-based
cannabinoid medicine approved by the fda
in the united states it's
not synthetic there are you know marinol
and sesame on the market these are
synthetic cannabinoids this
is cbd derived from plant it's 98
pure the fda has approved it for use
in two severe uh pediatric uh pediatric
sorry three severe pediatric epilepsies
dravet syndrome lennox gusto and
tuberous sclerosis
it was initially a schedule five on the
controlled substance act and now it has
been descheduled
as of april of 2020 and here's just a
picture of uh
kind of what it looks like it is covered
by insurance either fully for certain
conditions or partially
uh for some what we would call off-label
conditions
and i do tell people this is an option
because it does alleviate the
the very high financial burden of a high
dose cbd in
in patients who require high doses
now in that the epidiolex trials i'm not
going to go through everything
but i just want to share
these patients we're getting much higher
doses uh 20 milligram per kilo and even
up to 50 milligram per kilo as you can
see
and uh what we see here is for dravet
syndrome
for cbd the monthly frequency decrease
seizures it went from 12 seizures to
12.4 down to 5.9 and you can see placebo
from
14.9 to 14.1 clinically uh statistically
significant
and then you see here too uh percent of
patients having
a 50 reduction clearly statistically
significant
and then if you look at over time and
for the
study that was uh put out in 2018
looking at genetic syndromes you'll see
at week 12
they saw 50 of patients had a 50
reduction
and that number climbed over time by
week 48
57 and then if you look here you also
see for kids with lennox
guesto they again measured it a little
bit differently the median percentage
reduction
in drop seizures a certain type of
seizure that's common
in this condition uh with cbd
uh almost 44 percent of patients saw a
reduction versus the placebo of about 22
percent
um and so epidiolex as a cbd product
surely
clearly is showing some benefits uh
one of the things that we have been
seeing with epidiolex that we're not
really seeing with whole plant
uh necessarily is that
with patients on um valproic acid a
particular
seizure medication that we can see some
abnormalities on liver function tests
however these are reversible
and will resolve either with a reduction
of the cbd or reduction
of the valproac acid dosing i just want
to share a case report this is a
beautiful
little girl that came to me one of my
first pediatric
patients and she's at the time was nine
years old she's now
15 i think close to 16. she has what's
called a congenital disorder of
glycosylation or cdg
and this is a disorder whereby the cells
cannot
build a compound called the glycoprotein
and therefore the cells don't function
normally and this is of course
throughout her whole body
and this condition includes seizures a
shortened lifespan poor muscle tone
severe developmental delay and so on
when she came to me
she had tried over 12 different
medications she
was having hundreds of seizures on her
eeg every day
she was severely developmentally delayed
and the only medication she was on was
phenobarbital
i started her on a high cbd low thc
preparation
artisanal or oil or a whole plant
cannabis
comp um preparation and we didn't see
any real significant seizure reduction
but she became more alert she started
tracking i
having eye contact tracking her parents
she started smiling she was happier
um and so after we titrated the dose up
if i normally if i get to about halfway
through the therapeutic range we see
really don't see any significant benefit
we'll keep it on board because
clearly she was seeing benefit for her
um
cognitive uh interaction but we did not
see
reduction of any significant reduction
of seizures so we added in thca and at
that point the combination gave us 90
seizure reduction over the years we've
tried multiple
different uh phytocannabinoids for this
child
and she's currently getting a mixture of
multiple
uh cannabinoids and according to her
mother this
blend gives her tremendous benefit
so she's getting cbd thca
thc cbda cbg and again they are separate
mostly separate um products that the
mother
you know draws up in syringes and gives
to her at meal time
her if you want to look at her cbd to
thc ratio which a lot of people like to
look at she's getting one part cbd to
1.7 part thc
almost a one to two ratio so this is
very different than high cbd low thc
her brain is responding to this
with tremendous improvement and when i
say tremendous i mean
she said mama for the first time when
she was 12 years old i saw the video
brought me to tears
she's using an ipad that she interacts
with for learning games and
communication her motor skills
are so much improved that she started
using a sippy cup by herself and she's
feeding herself
uh which nobody ever expected certainly
that she would not if
you know she didn't have these in the
first 10 years of life she wouldn't be
able to have these skills
later on and so she continues to um
advance and to do uh
uh more and more and according you know
to her parents she is just
she's present uh and she's certainly a
daddy's girl
she has nothing but eyes and hugs for
daddy
if he's in the room um and so
she's been on cannabis for over six
years and i have yet to see any evidence
of harm in this
child it has just been a tremendous
improvement in her quality of life
now moving on to autism uh what we are
seeing
is study after study coming out in the
literature just over the last
few years because um sorry autism is a
condition
that is very difficult to treat it's
heterogeneous meaning every child
presents differently that's why we call
it an autism spectrum disorder
but there is some evidence to show that
cannabis can and
can make a difference in uh for these
children just a quick literature review
so there's a case report from 2010 using
a synthetic uh thc called drabinol and a
six-year-old boy
and uh it's a very well-written article
this uh
boy was given drops of thc which
eventually worked out to be 3.6
milligrams total daily dose which is a
fairly low dose with a significant uh
improvement including decreased
hyperactivity irritability and so on
there have been other studies just in
the last two decades
linking genetic mutations
with autism and endocannabinoid system
deficit
also that if you alter the
endocannabinoid system in mice it can
result
in autistic type behavior and also
a very interesting study that showed
that increased anandamide activity
meaning giving
augmenting the endocannabinoid at
the cb1 receptor improved the social
impairment
in mice in a mice model of autism so
here's these little clues that tell us
about the endocannabinoid system
uh alterations and manipulation
of the endocannabinoid system might give
us
some benefits and clues in treating
children with autism now here's this is
a groundbreaking study that came out in
2013
where they showed that a white blood
cell so remember your white blood cells
part of your immune system do have
cannabinoid receptors and so by
drawing blood from a child without
having to go in their brain
to look at their endocannabinoid system
when you draw blood and you look at the
white blood cells you can see what's
going on
so in this bar graph uh under you see
ctl that's the control patients and what
you see there is the gene expression of
the various components of the
endocannabinoid system
we're all at 100 percent functioning
beautifully
okay and what we would call uh within
normal limits and then when you look to
your right you see the bar graph is all
over the place
and these are in patients with a d
autism disorder
and you can see that type 1 receptors
are off
type 2 receptors are often are elevated
and then other components that make up
the enzymes and the precursors of
your endocannabinoids also were abnormal
so here
this study documents an endocannabinoid
imbalance endocannabinoid system
imbalance in
human children with autism and then
the next study that was also
groundbreaking in 2018 out of stanford
they uh figured out a way to measure
plasma and
anandamide levels and this was part of
the study was they talk about their
um laboratory
procedure to measure and you can see
just look to the right the bar graph
autism patients are in blue and the
controlled patients what we call
neurotypical children are in
gold and you can see that the children
with autism have
lower plasma anandamide their
endocannabinoid
and and that was statistically
significant and
what's interesting about this and if you
look to the graph to the left this is
the probability of
autism diagnosis so as that number
higher number
means a higher probability and on the
bottom is the anandamide levels
and you can see the higher levels as you
go to the right
that the plasma and andamide levels were
decreased in children with autism such
that the anandamide concentrations
differentiated the autism cases meaning
the scientists could
could almost uh you know uh fully pick
out which children had autism based on
their blood level
um and you'll see in the next slide as
well
um that we there is now
um a supposition that maybe anandamide
levels
might be a biomarker for an earlier
diagnosis
of um autism now we usually wait
until a child is at least three to four
sometimes a little bit earlier than that
but usually
uh it's a diagnosis a clinical diagnosis
based on observation and
parent reports now maybe we have a
blood test that we can use to recognize
autism earlier and intervene or
intervene earlier in 2019
out of israel they published this lower
circulating endocannabinoids
in children and you can see that the
children
on the on the bar graph you can see that
children with autism
are in red and the control patients are
the white bar graph and as you can see
that they found statistically
significant uh lower levels of three
of our endocannabinoids the first uh bar
graph
documenting nandomide when we look
also at a clinical trial so in israel
they did a study where they selected
60 children with the most severe
behaviors excuse me
and they gave a 20 to 1 cbd to thc
preparation starting with 1 milligram
per kilo per day and working up to 10
milligram
per kilo per day but for those that
didn't respond they added in extra thc
essentially lowering that ratio and as
you can see 52
responded to the higher ratio another 22
percent responded
to the extra thc and the numbers are
quite
uh impressive 61 of parents report
behavioral outbreaks reduced
almost 40 uh report improved anxiety
almost 50 improved communication and so
on
only eight percent in this group needed
to add medications
and about 57
either stopped medications or lowered
dosing
um and that's pretty impressive and as
you can see dosing at the bottom
uh varied for cbd and we'll talk about
this cbd has a very wide range of
therapeutic
therapeutic dosing and thc a little more
narrow
um but certainly uh these are very
positive
uh uh results um another report
again out of israel published in 2019
188 patients who took cannabis between
2015 and 2017
most of them taking high cbd low thc at
six months
82 percent still in active treatment
that's a
very impressive number when you look at
clinical trials
30 products to try and very few
pharmaceuticals that don't have
pretty significant side effects the
conclusion here was cannabis is safe
effective and well tolerated
and when we look at dosing uh from this
same group
you know dosing matters but you can see
there's a very wide range so you'll see
across the bottom 15 30 45 these are
milligrams
per dose and most of these patients took
three times a day dosing so as you can
see
a number of patients on the left let's
say for 15 there's three patients
that we're taking 15 milligrams three
times a day when you move over to 60
milligrams you can see 15 patients were
taking 60 milligrams two times a day
but there were patients who required
much higher dosing and i applaud the use
of higher dosing because often
what happens with cbd is people try a
low dose they say it doesn't work it
didn't help my child or didn't help me
and then they give up and you must
understand that dosing
matters we don't absorb every milligram
so you must try higher doses
overall what i can share with you from
my experience with
uh uh many uh taking care of many
children with autism what we're seeing
is less anxiety less aggression
less temper tantrums less self-injurious
behavior
kind of less of all the things we don't
want and then better of the things that
we do want so better speech and focus
improve school performance better eye
contact
and better participation in therapy now
i put little asterisks
to three um three symptoms there uh
aggression temper tantrums and
self-injurious behavior and i did that
just to remind me to share with you that
it appears from my clinical experience
that if there is aggression and these
types of behavior self-injurious
that th cbd doesn't always do the trick
and
thc should be considered earlier rather
than later
and i explain that to families and i
tell them i know you're worried about
thc but in
low doses in combination with cbd and
even sometimes in higher doses because
remember if this child is amanda my
deficient we have to replace it and as
dr mushulem says
anandamide and thc mimic each other so
in a patient that's deficient you will
you can see high doses being used
without any evidence of
impairment or intoxication certainly to
help a child have a better quality of
life thc must be considered
now side effects they're temporary
they're reversible
and as i've mentioned i can resolve them
usually by changing the dose the product
the preparation the timing
or using a different cannabinoid
we do see increased restlessness
hyperactivity
sometimes i see increased emotionality
with cbd as an interesting
side effect and then of course any
impairment or intoxication we don't
tolerate this we change
the dosing products and so on to make
sure that we are not going
uh to um have a child where we just
trade one
you know behavior for a side effect
and all parents are required to log
symptoms side effects improvements so
that we can
really kind of narrow in on what's
causing what
and try to tweak dosing and it's a
there's a lot of tweaking but in general
if a child
is showing evidence of a response
we can usually dial it in here's a case
report
of a patient who came to me at the age
of 16
he's a little bit older now and
severe aggression non-verbal highly
self-injurious
terrible anxiety and this is a kid who
just did not sleep
and if you've had any experience with
families with children with autism this
is across the board i mean i have
patients that
have hired nannies or somebody to come
in at night and stay with the child
who's awake so that the parents at least
could get a few hours of sleep i mean
imagine that
your child just doesn't sleep um this is
a young man whose father is very savvy
he had uh started with another uh
doctor i think and gotten some input and
had tried
over 20 cannabis products with no
success and i remember kind of thinking
as he went through all those products i
thought well
maybe he's not a responder i wonder you
know maybe he hasn't found the right
product
and then when i kind of looked at
everything he tried high dose cbd
was not ever included and at the time
that i saw him he was on very high dose
thc just to
kind of rein in behavior so that nobody
would get hurt including him
but he was starting to lose the
medicinal benefits due to the tolerance
that happens when you take
high dose cbd by itself and so
we started a high cbd low thc
27 to 1 ratio 100 milligrams three times
a day right out of the gate
so 300 milligrams it's a big boy and
within
basically one to two days this was he
was calm his father reported me
reported to me he was happy that his was
showing affection which he had never
done
and we were able to then lower the thc
amount so that we could retain the
benefits without
you know continuing to have tolerance
and his dosing regimen has changed over
time i believe this is where he's at now
cbd around 150 a milligram
three times a day and thc still high
dose 50 milligrams three times about a
three to one ratio
and you know i get reports from the
father everything's great he's great and
they've even started
um uh traveling um despite kovan just
going in the car
uh visiting family of course safely and
so on with covid but just to get him out
of the house because
uh you know his options have been
limited in terms of his continuation
programs in school
but really has changed his life for the
better um and
here he is you can see blowing out his
birthday candles uh
um uh and just uh it's been a
an honor to help this child uh find some
peace
um now i'm just gonna move on to
pediatric cancer just i only have one
slide on this this is a whole talk in it
of itself
but no question that cannabis can help
with symptomatic relief
of cancer symptoms and also symptoms
that come from
cancer treatment i have patients that
come in who have had tremendous weight
loss
either from just unable to eat nausea
vomiting but also mucositis which is
when you get severe
irritation in the mouth sores in the
mouth from the chemo
helps with sleep anxiety pain nerve pain
called neuropathy
no question a better quality of life and
many of my patients respond to low-dose
cannabinoids with this
in fact i just did a checkup with a
little boy who's getting
treatment for high-risk leukemia he
takes a total
of one milligram of thc in the morning
one milligram in the afternoon
and i believe a little higher dose at
night for sleep
and has completely turned around the mom
says he's playful
happy i mean before he was just
miserable
uh with severe mucositis so painful for
him
and so he's eating he's playing he's
sleeping she said he's just a different
child
um and of course this very low dose is
not going to interfere with
um his treatment and certainly uh
has clearly been beneficial now i've had
some patients come in at end of life
with advanced cancers with very poor
prognoses where the parents come to me
and say is there anything that cannabis
can do
and we do have evidence in the
scientific literature that cannabinoids
from the plants specifically thc cbd and
now more studies on cbg
can inhibit cancer cell growth can cause
apoptosis which is
causes the cancer cells to commit
suicide that
these compounds can inhibit metastasis
and also inhibit what we call
angiogenesis which is
the growth of blood vessels where
cancers grow their own blood vessels to
feed themselves
and so um remember this is these are
patients that are usually end of life
coming to me in very dire straits
where i will offer treatment and so um
there's a young man that came to me in
2015 was given about
you know three to six months to live
with stage four osteosarcoma which is a
particularly nasty bone cancer and i put
him on high dose cbd and thc
and he responded beautifully now this
was in conjunction with
low-dose what was called palliative
chemo
at the time they had not discontinued
chemotherapy
very hard to have that conversation with
people but
um his oncologist was all for cannabis
and she just left them on the chemo and
at the three-month mark this kid went
through all the various
tests pep scan cat scan mri and bone
scan
and we were all shocked to see that his
cancer was gone he is now over five
years without cancer thriving in college
and also working part-time um
just doing great um i took care of a
three-year-old that had a relaxed
mixed leukemia who got a bone marrow
transplant which also failed her
we had her in remission um from leukemia
within eight weeks of high dose cbd thc
in a plant-based diet she was not taking
any other treatment as the parents had
opted out
for you know anything further because
they just felt that her quality of life
was
not good with treatment she was uh
basically what we call nad no evidence
of disease for eight months
and for whatever reason i still don't
know to this day the family stopped the
oil and she did relapse
and so i have seen this before with some
other adult patients
and i usually recommend that if you get
to a point where cannabis has helped you
achieve
freedom from cancer it's probably not a
good idea to stop
another patient with stage 4
osteosarcoma similar to
the first one this is a child who came
in with a massive
pulmonary tumor metastatic tumor that
was inoperable
she had two tumors basically breaking
through in her legs just
nasty tumors you know bulging through
her legs
and we got her on high dose cannabinoids
and there was shrinkage
um immediately you know basically in the
if after six weeks
she was able she was oxygen dependent
when i met with her because of that
pulmonary tumor she was able to get off
oxygen she was taking high dose pain
meds she got off of that
she wasn't able to walk she started
walking again even
you know before kobet flew to visit a
friend in colorado
her father is an engineer
type and was really going by the cat
scans and the mris and measuring the
tumor in the lungs and we were able to
see that her overall tumor burden was
decreased by 95
after cannabis was added and
she was able to have that pulmonary
tumor it became operable because it
shrunk down to a
size that they could take out and what
they found when they
um biopsied this tumor is that
it was only five less than five percent
cancer cells but most of it was
basically dead tissue so she continues
on treatment
but uh according to her oncologist who
spoke to me
uh multiple times but basically a year
after we started her she said to me i
sent
her to you for you know hospice
palliative
uh properties and here she is a year
later with less cancer and doing great
so
there's something there we should be
free to study this
i have a two-year a two-year-old she's
not two anymore she's
taller than me now she had wilms tumor
uh she had a relapse
we had her in remission within six
months she was able to stop chemo early
and she's over
five years without
cancer and thriving and then another
young man
with stage four osteosarcoma who
cancer was progressing his oncologist
was on board to try cannabis and
we got him off opiates he started
walking again and he has con
continued on treatment with an improved
prognosis
where he overall has much less cancer in
his body than when he came to me
and happy to say his parents just
reported that he'll be starting college
uh in september of this year uh so
there's something there
and we should be studying this we should
not be prohibited this is uh
these are children who likely
would not have done well without a
cannabis in the picture
now considerations for pediatric
patients obviously benefit versus risk
always always always if i have a
patient coming in who is seizure free on
a pharmaceutical
and they just say well we just don't
like the idea of the drug and we want to
switch there are no guarantees with
cannabis
and for the most part if your child
seizure free
and you can have follow-up eegs at
some point your child may actually be
able to get off medication
um and so to me although
i think cannabis is great if you are
achieving the end goal with another
um product
or or a different medication that's
proven to work and
has those scientific studies behind it
i don't know that it's always beneficial
to switch
one of the other considerations is
certainly as you've learned all these
kids that come to me are
are um medically complex
they're usually on medication and they
can have drug drug interactions you must
be aware of that and again that's
another whole
uh talk but when we talk about products
so if you're interested to know like so
what about the products that we're using
so we always want to use concentrated
usually these are liquids like tinctures
or what we call oils
you want them to be concentrated if
there's one milligram
in a teaspoon and your child needs 200
milligrams that's not going to work
the only one that i don't like
concentrated is thc because we want to
be able to accurately
uh give low doses i want to be able to
measure out one milligram
but with cbd and the other compounds
concentrated oils allow children to take
less
volume and these products don't taste
good so it can be challenging to get
them into children
uh timing of doses is important if your
child needs every four hour dosing and
is doing great
how are we going to get your child
dosing in school right now
schools prohibit except in one
particular case in california schools
prohibit
any cannabis on campus so i have
families that have to drive in
at lunchtime take their school off
campus give them their
uh medicine and then put them back in
the classroom this disrupts the child's
day this disrupts the parents day so
this is another issue that of course we
need to resolve
we want to make sure products are
consistent batch to batch if i buy
a bottle of cbd oil that helps my child
i don't want to buy
next month's bottle and find out it's
something different
it's very important that you have that
consistency as well as a reliable source
somebody who says oh i made a batch of
oil
or gets it hey my friend gave me some
oil it's great it worked great
and now you can't get it again well
that's not great medicine right because
if you can't repeat it
that's not going to work affordability
is an issue cbd can be expensive in high
doses
and this is often why some families go
to epidiolex again because it's covered
by insurance
local access i have families that will
drive four hours in one direction to
pick up oil
a certain product for their child and
again in california now that we are
legalized
medically and for adult use one would
think that access has gotten better and
it's actually gotten worse
so that has not helped the the medical
patients
of of course it goes without saying lab
tested
and of course something that must be
understood
and accepted at the beginning of
treatment is that
uh children are growing and changing
that's what they do that's what they're
supposed to do their brain is growing
their body is growing they're changing
developing um dosing changes their
response to medications change sometimes
something works for a year and then it
doesn't work anymore this is
uh this happens with pharmaceuticals and
certainly happens with
cannabinoids and you know i joke around
that children are a moving target but
this is clearly what i've seen now often
what i get is what about the developing
brain so most studies that have looked
at
effects have looked at unregulated
chronic heavy thc
used in a non-medical fashion
that cannot be compared to a child who
may have an endo underlying
endocannabinoid system
uh dysfunction so we cannot compare its
apples and oranges
now certainly unregulated chronic heavy
thc
use in teenagers when the brain is
vulnerable
to external substances during a very
important
maturation process we do know that there
may be some risk of anxiety impulsivity
issues memory problems attention
decision making executive function
and potentially this decrease in iq and
again these studies only looking at
chronic heavy
thc use they're not looking at children
using cannabis medically
to treat a serious medical condition
in 2018 a study came out that looked at
almost 2 000 twins where their iq was
tested at age
5 12 and 18 and executive
function was tested at 18 as well and
very
interestingly they measured out who was
using cannabis and who wasn't
and with twin studies you kind of get a
baseline for that kind of genetic
and home environmental factors it kind
of is the equalizer there and what they
found and what they reported was that
lower iq and poorer executive function
was not due to cannabis use but it was
due
more likely to family background factors
which is
a very important information and again
this is in
uh people who are using cannabis
non-medically we must separate
medical from recreational use they are
not
the same in my clinical experience
children with severe
and chronic conditions taking cannabis
medicine under medical supervision
are making developmental and
neurocognitive progress
this is what i see this is what i do for
a living i see it every day
now last slide legal issues of course
always check the laws in your state or
your country
you want to make sure that if you're
treating a child you have legal approval
you want to avoid issues with child
protective services
i have a handful of patients that have
been reported
either by their physician a neurologist
or by a therapist or by
someone in the family who holds a grudge
uh and child protective services gets
involved
you want to have that legal protection
in the state of california
i am allowed to treat children with
cannabis it is state sanctions so nobody
should be getting in trouble when
they're doing it right
most states and countries if there is a
law require physician approval for
anybody under 21
and then i just wanted to list some of
the best free resources for patients so
safe access now
which is americans for safe access and
again i'm on their
policy advisory committee they're a
wonderful group that has fought for
freedom to use cannabis
medically and adult use as well
normal is the national organization for
reform of marijuana laws
excellent group who also by the way both
of these
websites have state by state information
if you're looking for
information on your particular state's
regulations and approvals for cannabis
realmscaring.org is a wonderful group
that
was involved with treating children with
epilepsy with cbd at the very beginning
from way back when and then united
patients group another
patient advocate group that can help
point you in the right direction
and then just thank you very much these
are some of the patients that i've
talked about
and so always happy to see their cute
little faces
um i appreciate your time and
hope that this lecture was able to share
with you how
i use cannabis in children with
complex medical conditions
you